Мене діти надихають.
Ви знаєте, що мудрі казали:
«Дитина — це і є справжня людина».
Вони не лукаві.
І це та чудова глина, з якої можна творити.
А творчість завжди надихає.
Спікування... Не дарма тут написано
Homo ludens (людина граюча),
це як форма існування людини на Землі —
через гру.
Так, за перше місце нагороджується Попович Владислав.
Поаплодуємо, діти.
Це його перший успіх.
Вітаю, Владислав.
[лунають оплески]
Справа в тому, що він довго йшов до цього успіху,
йому не вдавалося це.
Але він місяць за місяцем ходив сюди,
він добився свого.
Молодець.
У самому центрі — 235 учнів.
Але до мене ходить значно більше.
Нині в них був такий турнір дуже гарний — «Біла тура».
Ми почали вигравати в області і Західній Україні.
Ми працювали дійсно дуже сумлінно і багато.
Отримали це приміщення в 1986 році.
Тут була цементна підлога,
бігали щури по тих ... і так далі.
За всі ці роки помаленьку-помаленьку
ми покращували кожен куточок.
Намагалися робити з любов’ю.
Меблева фабрика в нас працювала,
ми зробили спецзамовлення.
Столи в мене вже з 1988 року.
Це шахи «Стаунтон» — англійська фірма,
на якій грають шахісти міжнародних турнірів.
З Києва, тренер шахів.
У Варшаві чемпіонат Європи був команди.
Він туди поїхав і привіз мені.
З часом, коли фінансування стало більш проблематичним,
я дещо змінив вектор.
Я тут проводжу грудневі вечори класичної музики.
Я перейшов просто на те,
щоб дитині тут було комфортно,
щоб вона відчувала атмосферу затишку і свободи.
Звичайно, це місце — дуже ласий шматок, в центрі міста.
І тільки тому що,
вибачте за нескромність, я тут,
це місце ще зберігає свою функцію.
Один з моїх найулюбленіших образів — ось.
Це, в принципі, воно і описує кредо мого життя,
тому що ця людина ще обтяжена думкою про те,
що краще там, де нас немає.
Він зібрався іти туди,
а цей чоловік уже повертається,
бо він зрозумів, він уже просвітлений.
Подивіться, яка це обтяжлива постать, а ця легка.
Дивіться, який, ось...
І він махає рукою, вітає тебе з днем,
зі світлом, радістю тебе вітає.
Він зрозумів, що не важливо
де ти є, а важливо який ти є.
Якщо ти є якісний, творець, то ти на тому місці,
яке тобі так було таким нудним,
ти зробиш те, що буде цікаве.
Я вже вчитель третього покоління.
Тобто для мене це середовище — як дихати.
Із батьком я починав, це був сьомий клас.
А потім, вже як батько привіз з Москви мені книжки.
А потім, коли я зрозумів, що мені
хочеться грати, уже суперників треба шукати,
я брав дошку собі під руку
і ходив по Костополю, як диригент зі свічкою
серед білого дня шукав людину,
так і я шукав з ким, мені знайти партнера.
У мене не було тих людей,
які б мені заважали.
Цей попутний вітер у вигляді людей,
які розуміли мене і допомагали мені,
вони були постійно [біля мене].
Мені Господь дав зі старту таку плеяду дітей,
що просто розкошувати можна було.
Це велика відповідальність, в той же час, і велике щастя.
Це надихнуло мене, і тому я пішов далі.
Фрески Робери, Лондон, от Бонна,
Іра Буляхович, Булонський університет.
От Бельгія, от знаєте, статуя,
студенти собі на голову...
Будапешт... Це Віктор грає на
Всесвітній універсіаді за збірну МГУ,
це пам'ять, пам'ятна [світлина].
За збірну грає МГУ з Угорщиною.
Це собачка...
Ага, думав що одразу мат?..
Ми гарно ведемо дитину до школи, дитсадок,
ми гарно ведемо її в школі, позашкілля у нас чудове.
В інститут дитина попадає,
теж університет веде її до цього.
Здобуває гарну освіту.
І після цього наступає момент великого суму.
Що ти нікому не потрібен.
У нас не відпрацьовано ринок праці абсолютно.
І скільки у нас уходить наших молодих талановитих мізків,
їде на Захід, там де вони [працюють],
а повинні були тут творити їхню, власну Україну.
Завдання вчителя в чому полягає?
Виховати особистість, вивести її до порога
і надати їй, відкрити їй цей світ.
А хто може виховати особистість?
Тільки вільний вчитель.
Сама система стосунків так побудована ще від того часу,
що вчитель не є вільний у багатьох питаннях.
Це велика проблема.
Якщо ми хочемо змінити суспільство,
ми повинні міняти правила гри в освіті в першу чергу.
Наприклад, дати відпочинку більше.
Вчитель повинен читати.
Якщо він не читає, він не буде цікавий дітям.
Автоматично він не відбудеться.
Дуже гарна тенденція останніми роками
прослуховується, проглядається.
Тому що молоді батьки ведуть дітей.
Вони починають розуміти,
що дитину потрібно розвивати.
І коли є такі можливості,
то це ж треба робити.
Українець — це стан душі.
Це...
Чи доля наша, чи біда, чи щастя,
ми з вами живемо на стику двох цивілізацій —
європейської і азіатської.
І на цих міграційних шляхах
протягом століть стільки тут намішано.
Це маленька країна і народ невеликої чисельності,
йому швидше прийти, як кажуть, до гурту.
Так само і нам треба пройти.
Плюс ми спадщину ідеологічну отримали таку,
що нам ще треба довго зализувати рани.
Через Україну пройшли дві світові війни:
туди і назад, знову туди й назад.
Після таких ран
будь-яка держава не швидко оговтається.
А ми, при тому всьому,
зберегли це,
і мову зберегли, і молодь яка у нас.
І ті самі Майдани: це ж непросто так.
Вони показали це як архетип української спільноти.
Це гурт, це порада, це єдність,
це громада, це товариство.
Якщо ми до цих початків прийдемо,
то у нас все буде гаразд.